hello dr. Berg here in this video we're gonna
talk about keto and dairy okay can you do dairy
on a keto now in this video I'm not going to talk
about lactose intolerant or allergies to milk or
casein if the protein in milk I'm mainly gonna
talk about should you do dairy on a ketogenic
diet or not first let's talk about the yogurt
okay fat-free yogurt with fruit so called fruit
healthy which usually it's like not just fruit
it's like the jelly of the fruit and all the
sugar and sometimes it's not even fruit at all
it's kind of artificial flavoring it's 47 grams
of sugar that's like drinking a soda that's a
lot of sugar fat-free plain is 19 grams of sugar
that's incredible fat-free Greek is 9 grams so
it's a little bit better but it's still too high
and this is per 8 ounces okay eight ounces so
it's a cup whole milk plain is 11 grams of sugar
that's still too high but look at fat-free plain
versus whole milk plain apparently the fat-free
is higher in in sugars see I'm not even looking
at the carbohydrates I'm looking just in sugar
so yeah so that's interesting so whole milk plain
is better than fat-free plain fat-free vanilla is
34 grams of sugar way too high goats milk kefir
is 7 grams so if you were forced to consume some
type of yogurt or kefir obviously this would be
the best this is the second best okay if you were
at gunpoint and you had eaten right okay look at
this blueberry kefir 20 grams Wow low fat plain
kefir still has 12 grams of sugar low fat plain
key for 11 grams of sugar this is lactose free
and I don't understand why it's high in sugar but
because lactose is the sugar so I don't I don't
understand that but it's still it's way too high
so that's yogurt so do you want to do yogurt on keto
the answer is no I'm sorry okay now let's get to
milk 2% milk is 12 grams of sugar per cup okay cup
is not that big that's too high half-and-half for
your coffee 0.36 grams so it's less than a gram
and whole cream like whipping cream is 0.1
so if you were to use cream in your coffee though
with the whole milk but still happen happens not
that bad okay so can you do these yes I would
get organic and try to get grass-fed if possible
and this one is a No now what if you do it just
a little bit of milk okay that's fine but not a
lot of milk okay it's just gonna blow you out of
ketosis let's talk about cheese now when you have
cheese you have this fermentation product that you
have these bacteria that are eating up the milk
sugar and a lot of that lactose is being lost
with the whey the protein part as it's coming
out of cheese in the making of cheese as well but
check this out cream cheese is less than one one
gram it's point four five grams per cup that's
pretty good so cream cheese is totally fine pepper
jack is zero grams of sugar awesome cheddar it's
zero grams in fact the more aged of cheeses the
better the less sugar it has mozzarella one point
four grams of sugar per cup still not bad has a
little bit more but look at this processed cheese
processed cheese you know those little individual
wrapped cheese that most people consume probably
Velveeta and the other processed cheese that you
would buy that everyone's eating and lunch and the
whole thing 19 grams of sugar 19 grams of sugar
for processed cheese that is like way over the top
cottage cheese is six grams Wow that's it that's a
good amount of sugar so is this a yes or no these
are a yes these are probably a no all right small
amounts but this one's definitely a big fat no
okay now you might be allergic to cheese because
the casein the allergy that's a separate deal you
might be lactose intolerant that's a separate deal
but when you get consume cheese grass-fed organic
would be the ideal scene okay thanks for watching
hi guys hey listen I created a pretty amazing
evaluation quiz down below that actually analyzes
your symptoms to find the cause the root cause of
all of your symptoms the most likely cause so
take the quiz now and we'll send you a report